let's plug this guy in
we are here with johnny boz how's it
going the apocalypse is starting it
doesn't seem safe
[Applause]
they're coming they're coming
[Music]
[Music]
we got a super high level in the hotel
check out this amazing amazing view
check out this uh
this balcony
huh
the only thing better than like the top
floor is like the bottom what no don't
do it
let me in
come on i'm here to speak on a panel
i'll be on it with ben swanson from
ubisoft and our good friend ricky ray
butler and don't forget the world's
greatest devin graham
big one dude you're so sharp now you
guys gotta clean yourself these guys
aren't good at cleaning their lenses i'm
not i don't i don't clean one i used to
be impressed with these guys not anymore
three minutes ago we were cutting edge
now we don't clean our lenses you guys
should see the rig though it's like a
microphone on a microphone on the
microphone what up i'm talking and
coming back
it's not perfect whatever
camera full conversation it's pretty
interesting that this mic is picking me
up really loudly loudly like this will
be clearer
they gave us some luggage
same people who made friends super
powerful graphic rendering machines
super super small skyway is the name of
the luggage if you're interested
so if you look at the front of the
machine it's a nice
nice
stop that stop that press the button
don't push my button
in the back here this one has one 1080
ti black magic 4k 10-bit card so we can
plug into a 10-bit monitor other specs
they're listed on the screen now
it's like cute animals with like
wide-angle lenses look at my schnoz look
at that
that's not shot
we did flower warfare and i remember
this very distinctly we were driving in
the car and we're like dang we can't do
blood on youtube it's too like we'll get
content flagged and it's like what else
could we do flower petals are red it's
like okay well okay what feels like a
flower thing it's like okay then what if
it was like oh and then sunflowers could
be the muzzle flares like okay well then
if that's gonna be that then maybe it's
a story about like two stoners who are
like kind of hallucinating like a flower
like sort of thing but that idea came
from dang we don't want to get content
flagged on youtube anymore we released a
video called no time to explain because
we were shooting time travel series and
i was getting really frustrated with
everyone like wait how does time travel
work like if he travels from here in the
past to here in the future where is he
in between and it's just like let's make
a video where we just don't explain
anything that's going on because i'm
just so sick of it frustrations are a
really great source of inspiration you
love something you'll be like i like
that but if something makes you angry
you'll be like i need to prove that that
thing sucks yes our new pc can handle 4k
video supposedly we constantly shoot
1080 video on the saminiko channel
ideally with this computer we can start
shooting a bunch of 4k stuff on the
saminiko channel but we need to stress
test this see how far this can get
pushed so we're going to use
our big red
shoot as uncompressed as possible at the
highest resolution possible and see how
well this computer can handle it my
usual settings i shoot on the red for a
youtube channel 5k hd 20 to 1
compression ratio sometimes 16 to 1 if
i'm shooting very deep focus if there's
a lot of detail or night time if i'm
shooting a professional series or movie
compression setting is usually eight to
one 6k the lowest you can do i think is
two to one we need really fast mags for
that and the highest you can go is i
think 22 to one so it's referring to
lossless one to one for every pixel you
have one pixels worth of encoding
our red card is 64 gigabytes the camera
is set to 5k five to one we're allowed
seven minutes of footage every minute
will be nine gigs if this computer can
handle this footage it can handle any 4k
footage that the salmon eco channel will
get
seems pretty smooth now i'm going to go
down to quarter which is basically hd
very smooth really smooth
now we normally edit red footage at 1 8.
so this is twice
the quality than we normally edit red
footage with put it up a notch let's put
it up a notch and how we're going to do
that is we're going to duplicate it so
we're at two layers
oh man
staying pretty strong it's usually
around that orbit
that the chugging starts happening so it
handled it double or double double the
double so now we got four layers normal
computer cannot play four left players
wow
still can handle it oh man we got eight
layers
nice
right home let's go to 16.
oh my god
not bad 32 it is i've noticed a
big difference when i have more than one
layer of footage in my pen you've
noticed a difference when you have more
layers okay so this should be doing
stuff
just let it play though let's see how
fast it corrupts though because once it
starts cutting around that's where the
real chugging starts usually happening
i could be wrong though
32 duplicated layers of 5k
7-1 raw video sorry nick did you say
64 layers
i did i actually dreamed it
oh
it's chugging
but that's pretty impressive i'm not
gonna lie so now let's color correct it
this is when i hurt the processor a lot
at full resolution whoa
look at this premier is
yeah
definitely chugging doesn't like 64
layers dude
i'm pretty sure that any footage that we
toss at this computer
it'll handle it
thanks pj
[Music]
here
four half dollars we're just gonna make
them jump from one dude all right
what's up
[Music]
last one
[Music]
[Applause]
how many screams do you think you guys
will get none because our fans are way
cooler than that
we're going to do a meet and greet going
down here these guys are going the wrong
way it's line two it says on the street
i know the one that reads the pdfs that
get sent to us
oh they're saying it's down there
oh
[Applause]
dude we got some mints
it is 10 a.m in the morning but we
didn't get breakfast so we're gonna go
get lunch that's a good idea
imagine a street meat guy set up his
grill here he'd make a killing all that
street meat marinade
i'm gonna get that
angus steak
burger
guess what
what
we have a lot of extra fidget spinners
we have a lot of extra monopods
and wasn't there one other thing
so you know these limited edition things
we keep talking about yes they are
actually limited edition
but we have overstock of a couple of
stuff sometimes when you guys are like
yo that's a cool hat and then you cancel
the order right away the hat still gets
made
everything must go and then we buy you
that hat back from you at cost first
show them the hat all right so there's
gonna be three giveaways
on a video or two after this
announcement right here how are we
giving away how are we determining who's
getting the hats well it's very simple
on this video leave a comment that is
one sentence in one sentence only not a
run-on sentence okay that doesn't count
and we're gonna read through them and
we're gonna laugh about them have a
couple jokes pick out the good ones and
then we'll contact you guys and ask you
which items you would like and you guys
subscribe and turn it off yeah you have
to be a subscriber we're not gonna give
out
items to non-subscribers you may have
seen us using these super awesome
ifootage monopods now this isn't a
sponsored video
basically they just said hey we really
like the fact that you guys use our gear
we're gonna send you more
and we want you
to give them away
oh so fun story
for the last month and a half i haven't
been able to uh charge my phone
or like barely able to charge it it's
very finicky about a week ago i found
out oh i had to clean out the lightning
bolt port because it was just
filled with gunk i did that and charging
was no problem apparently starting today
my phone won't let me charge it anymore
because all the cables i use are not
compatible with iphone
it says it let me get i'll get a paint
cable let me get a cable i'm going to
plug it into the outlet
what kind of it's an iphone
all right
so a little battery because i can't
[ __ ] try it
and
uh
[ __ ] it's charging
what where's that other cable
there you go this accessory may not be
supported
that's because it's a jank third-party
cable but it's the same exact cable here
actually let me see if my phone works
with this one
here's the true test
what's the problem
and put it back how i had it
yeah the computer needs it but
will it accept the charge
look at the corner of your phone
no it's not charging oh it's just the
cable this it's this specific cable the
specific cable is dead oh thank god
having so many issues with iphone